- [Voiceover] We've
seen in previous videos
that photosynthesis can be broken down
into the light-dependent
reactions and the Calvin cycle.
And the light-dependent reactions is
where we take light as an
input along with water,
and we'll see the water is
actually a source of electrons,
and we can use that to store energy
in the form of ATP and NADPH,
and as a by-product we
produce molecular oxygen,
which is very important for us to breathe.
And then that ATP and that NADPH
can be used in the Calvin cycle,
along with carbon dioxide,
to actually synthesize sugar.
What we're gonna focus on in this video
are the light-dependent reactions.
How does this process right here work?
And to help us think about this,
we're going to zoom in
onto a thylakoid membrane.
So this is a thylakoid right over here,
sitting inside of the chloroplast.
And if we zoom in on its membrane,
we see it's a phospholipid bilayer,
like many membranes
that we see in biology.
And at first glance, this might seem
like a very complex diagram,
and that's because it
is a complex diagram,
and you will often see things like this
in your biology textbooks.
They can be very intimidating,
these proteins and molecules and complexes
have very complicated-sounding names,
but the general idea
of what's going on is,
you'll hopefully find,
pretty straightforward.
You have the energy from light,
photons from light are going to,
either directly or
indirectly, excite electrons.
Those excited electrons,
they're in a high-energy state.
They're gonna be transferred
from one molecule to another,
and they're going to go
to lower energy states.
That's what allows those transfers
to be as spontaneous, for
them to actually occur.
They're going from a high-energy state
to a lower-energy state.
The electrons are getting more
and more and more comfortable,
and some of that energy that's released
as the electron goes
from a high-energy state
to a lower-energy state
is used to pump hydrogen
ions across the membrane.
From the outside of the
membrane, in the stroma,
to the inside of the membrane,
to within the thylakoid lumen.
So you are building a hydrogen
ion concentration gradient.
Concentration gradient.
Where you have a higher
concentration inside
than you have outside.
And this by itself,
this concentration gradient as we'll see,
can be used to fuel the production
of ATP by ATP synthase,
that those hydrogen ions
want to get back out.
They wanna go down their
concentration gradient,
and as they go back out
through the ATP synthase
it essentially turns that motor
that can jam the phosphate
group onto ADP to produce ATP.
So one way to think about it,
this is producing a hydrogen ion gradient.
So we could do it this way,
we could say H plus gradient,
which is then being used
to produce the actual ATP.
Now the electrons going
from a high-energy state
to a lower-energy state in this part
of the light-dependent reactions,
that by itself isn't the only
thing that is contributing
to the hydrogen ion
concentration gradient.
Once that electron gets donated,
you might say, well how
does it get replaced?
Well the thing that's doing the donating,
the thing that eventually gets excited
and donates that electron,
it's a chlorophyll a
variation called P680.
P680 is referring to the
P stands for pigment,
680 stands for 680 nano-meters,
the wavelength of light
that it absorbs best.
And so when it gets excited, it becomes
you'll see the notation off of P680*,
that's when it has an excited electron.
And then after it gives away its electron,
it becomes P680+
with a positive charge.
And this P680, we could call it P680 plus
right over here, maybe a P680 ion,
this is actually a very
strong oxidizing agent.
One of the strongest,
if not the strongest,
that we know in biological systems.
And so it really likes to grab
electrons from other things.
And the thing that is around
that it can grab electrons
from is actually water.
And so this is such a
strong oxidizing agent
that it can essentially
oxidize the oxygen in water,
and oxygen as itself.
I mean, oxidizing is named after oxygen
because oxygen is such a strong,
it's so electronegative,
it's such a strong,
it's the thing that's
normally doing the oxidizing.
So anyway, it grabs its electrons,
once it gets this P680+,
grabs an electron from water,
and then the water essentially falls apart
so you're left just with the oxygen
and then the hydrogen ions.
And so those hydrogen ions also contribute
to the increased hydrogen ion
concentration on the inside.
And this is where we get
the oxygen by-product
right over here.
Here we have one half of an
O2, so if you do this twice
you're going to have a molecular oxygen.
So, so far we've talked about
how the oxygen gets produced,
we've talked about how
the ATP gets produced.
What about the NADPH?
Well we've started our
process in photosystem II.
You might say, why's it
called photosystem II
if that's where we start?
Well it's actually that's because
that's the second
photosystem to be discovered.
You might say, what is a photosystem?
Well these photosystems and complexes,
they're combinations of
proteins and molecules,
and photosystem in
particular has chlorophyll
and variations of chlorophyll
and pigment molecules
that are responsive to
light that are very easy,
that have electrons that
can get excited by light,
and they can transfer that energy
back down to the P680 chlorophyll a pair,
which then can have its electron excited
and then it can give that
to an acceptor molecule
and then it can go to
lower, lower energy states
and pump those hydrogen ions out.
But that's not the entire
light-dependent reactions.
That electron can eventually make its way
over to photosystem I, and
why's it called photosystem I?
Well it's because the first
one that was discovered.
In photosystem I, there's another
chlorophyll a pair called P700,
and that's because it optimally absorbs
light of a wavelength of 700 nano-meters.
And you have something
similar that happens,
that light can either directly
or indirectly excite its electron.
And then that electron, as it
goes to a lower-energy level,
it goes from one molecule to another,
it can be used to reduce NADP+ into NADPH.
And so that's where the NADPH comes from.
And then once again, once the
P700 has given its electron,
it wants an electron,
and well it can get that from the electron
that's been going from lower
to lower, lower energy states,
that's essentially been
making its way from,
you can conceptualize it as the electron
that's been making its
way from photosystem II.
And so that's why you'll
often see these diagrams.
Lights come in, electron gets
energized, it gets excited,
it goes to lower and lower energy states.
As it's doing that it's being transferred
from one molecule to another,
being facilitated by enzymes.
That energy, part of that energy
is being used to transfer hydrogen ions
into the thylakoid
lumen, into the interior.
Then in photosystem I, you
have another excitation event.
That thing that got excited
can grab that electron
that went to lower, lower energy states,
and its excited electron can once again
be transferred from
one molecule to another
in order to fuel or provide energy
for NADP+ being converted into NADPH.
And once again the whole idea
of the hydrogen ion
concentration increasing here
can fuel ATP synthase, which
allows us to jam a phosphate
onto ADP to produce ATP.
So that is where we actually
get all of these things
and the by-product of
course is our oxygen.
And if you wanted to see that same idea
but kind of just thinking from
an energetic point of view
without all of the complexity
of seeing the physical
components involved,
you see it right over here.
Where you have light energy
comes, excites the electrons.
Once the P680 has given
that electron away,
it wants an electron really badly.
It gets it from the water.
And then as that electron goes
to lower and lower and
lower energy states,
it can eventually be grabbed by P700
that has given away its own electron.
And then that electron
that was excited at P700
by, once again, more light energy,
that can be transferred
from one molecule to another
to fuel the creation of NADPH.
And this part right over here,
this phase right over here,
as the energy goes from
a high-energy state to a-
as the electron goes
from a high-energy state
to a lower energy state,
fuels the pumping of hydrogen protons
into the actual thylakoid.